black ops 3 please welcome mark
Meah
hello playstation nation on behalf of
everybody a Treyarch and Activision it's
great to be here with black ops 3 we're
creating the deepest and most engaging
Call of Duty ever across the campaign
multiplayer and zombies and we've always
prided ourselves on building incredibly
social online experiences and now we're
bringing that same spirit to the
campaign where we developed a greedy
co-op experience from the ground up it's
not afraid to take you off the rails and
lets you play how you want from single
planets up to four friends on next-gen
the weapons equipment and character
abilities you'll earn through gameplay
are chosen before each mission how you
equip yourself changes the way you play
each encounter now we got four players
getting ready for battle now and the
year is 2065 and we're an off-the-books
mission in pursuit of a high-value
target and cairo egypt when all hell
breaks loose and as is the case in the
world of black ops if you want to
succeed sometimes you gotta get your
hands dirty
this is black ops 3
Brimley's coming in watch his step in
buckets hanging by a thread
[Music]
whoa-ho-ho fire friendly Winslow accord
damn
tell me please
you're still breathing all right I'm
gonna move
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
do